you're with the frenchman french
superstar maxine vashilagrav makes him
it it's been a wild event you look
around and somebody's in the lead then
they're no longer in the lead who's
playing hot who's not how do you feel
about your play so far
it's been uneven and um
yeah today i really
should have done better i feel
i had great position against levon uh
i had a great position against fabi
which i even managed to lose
i mean then i was worse against levan
but
and this game i really shouldn't have
an advantage at all but somehow peter
underestimated things and
i got some
promising continuation
what's the adjustment when you're
playing chess 960 um so it's all about
these 15 minutes so we're looking at the
positions generally a group or two of
two or three players depending on who's
playing who
you know
and
we find some fun ideas um
and for instance on the first day i
found
a great move on
in game two
against shah i played bishop before
actually fabi managed to
play that prep with black when he played
bishop b5 and we both won our games so
and like i was winning after move four
which rarely does
ever happens i mean not winning a pawn
or whatever just totally dominant
position
so those 15 minutes i mean it's used to
you're used to preparing for hours and
hours days and days
now that that's just out the window are
you the type of player who thinks
whatever i'm just gonna play chess uh
it's very important to get this first
few moves right and you know like for
instance game one against wesley i
didn't even consider his first move and
then run into big trouble so
it's really those 15 minutes are
actually crucial
you've been playing tennis
each day is that the appropriate
preparation for tomorrow as well
uh i hope so i've
i haven't played tennis in a long time
but so i'm trying to to improve my play
we saw peter on the court today maybe
you know tomorrow the woolfield
will be out on those tennis courts
all right well somehow i doubt that but
good luck tomorrow thank you maurice all
right